robots can first of all have access to
vast amounts of data so as you're moving
through an environment they could access
data on demand from things that they're
encountering figuring out what they need
to download remember in the matrix there
you could download a you know the
program of how to put something together
or how to interact with something now
robots are sharing information so when
one robot discovers a better way to pick
up a glass is instantly shared with all
the other robots this idea the
collective learning is enormously
exciting and that's changing the field
and for example that's what Google is
doing in the robotic car and the
advantage that Google has over the auto
companies is that they understand the
network so that car is constantly
getting downloading maps and images and
traffic and weather conditions and then
sharing it with all the other robot
procedures will be able to be performed
by the robot autonomously it's like
autopilot auto pilots are better than
human violence and landing and say foggy
conditions right so there's some things
that we will trust them with it's a very
real fear and I think the one thing we
certainly do have to worry about is jobs
I think this is a enormous issue that
technology is changing jobs and
moving them in the short term will be a
lot of disruption what we should start
thinking about is the multiplicity the
multiplicity is actually a very positive
idea it's where you have groups of
people of humans working together with
groups of machines we're already seeing
it to some degree you think about how
Google search engine works it's a it's
taking input for many many humans at the
same time is many many machine they're
all integrated together to give you
extremely good search results all the
commercial activity in particular Google
buying the robot companies Amazon's very
interested and there's really a real
sense of excitement that we're at an
inflection point for robotics